what's impressive about your portfolio
and it is a portfolio
like between ig and facebook and youtube
someone might blow up on one and they
may have a million followers on
instagram and then facebook they may
have like 5 000 likes
yeah all platforms most definitely
you're dominating it most definitely
that is that's very rare
like how we've been able to achieve like
such notoriety across
every platform see i would say i would
say because of the the content that i do
put out you know the stuff that i put
out
i like to relate i like to yeah
get in the mic there yeah i like the
relationship this is show biz
i'm preparing myself but um i like to
relate to the people
okay from young kids to the older
people you know what i'm saying um i do
a lot of character work
which involved like family you know so i
like to involve like you know family you
know relationship
problems family problems and you know
stuff that people went through you know
growing up
so like my age range is from like i
would say maybe like 14
and up but it's probably still some
younger people watch it but you know on
facebook it's the older crowd
yeah you know so i know what they like
and i know what they want to see and
it's like instagram although i know
this what they want to see and it's like
youtube
they like everything you know i'm saying
in twitter it's like
they can like everything you know but
facebook is like really just for the old
people
it's not too many young people that's on
like facebook i mean you have a few but
young people is more of instagram okay
and it's like
i kind of like found the balance you
know
with that i would say i mean i'm still
kind of
probably not at 100 but i'm at a
good percentage of you know with it so
you're
maybe creating content you'll only
release on facebook and stuff
you'll only release on instagram you
won't like cross-pollinate well now
i'm at a point where i make it fall
okay yeah you know what i'm saying
because everybody likes
the relationship problems everybody have
a baby mama that they deal with
you know from the young to the older
everybody
has the the bad child the bad kid
everybody have a grandmother
everybody have a uh uncle or a
granddaddy
you know they ca they do these things
that goes on in my video
so now it's like it's you know it's
leveled out
you know i'm saying to a point where i
can put it on
every platform but did that take time to
build into
yeah okay it took some time because you
know i would say like literally
like for real for real i really
just maybe found my niche and like you
know people really start to like
get involved more i would say probably
what is it 2018 now i would say
the beginning of 2017 was really when
things really started to
pick up pick up you know when i started
to see like that change big numbers
uh-huh what was that pivot you think um
once you know of course i got with some
great actresses you know i'm saying
shout out to b simone and
candice and you know nunu and just all
the people that i work with and
we all got that chemistry you know we
all connected well
you know what i'm saying we we built
that and we stayed consistent
you know and the people start to love it
you know i'm saying
my vision with what i do you know what
i'm saying of course i want to sit come
one day so yeah i try to put work in
with that so that people can like
visualize it as like a sitcom and you
know i get comments like oh my god i
can't wait to see this on tv
and that's like very inspiring to me
it's like okay i'm doing something
good that the people love so they can
like really see it on tv
you know so that's how i'm like wow i
got something yeah
you know just on the amount of time you
know i'm saying it
your team just stand close and everybody
believing that it can happen
not only me but them as well and sharing
the same vision yeah
cause it's like you know i mean i can't
do it by myself you know so and
it's not just about you know for me it's
it's for them too because this can be
something big for them as well
you know so that's that's how i look at
it and the people
they love it you know i i ate that part
of the day i probably freaked out if i
came in with another girlfriend
or another baby vomit they were like
wait a minute this is not no
you know yeah because they they like
what they say that's like
for example if martin brought in another
girlfriend
it's not gina man people like what is
this we want gina
you know so that's it's at a point i
feel like it's
it doesn't got they don't sunk into that
and people love it
and people love it on social media and
i'm sure you've been in the rooms with
very influential people now and powerful
people and
people almost the invisible hand of
entertainment and where the tide is
headed
do you even think tv is the way to go oh
man um social media is being so strong
man
and i wanna say tv but
so many people is on his phone yeah all
the time talking about with netflix with
youtube
with you even got the the stuff like hbo
and stars they got apps for that now
so it's like they can still just watch
it on their phone so it's like
i don't know it's like because i want to
make it to the tv okay and when i make
it to the tv
you need to be turned on the tv don't be
on your phone
so but i don't know man social media is
becoming a
real big impact to the world it's
becoming
too big man yeah i mean i'm not saying
it's a bad thing but
i mean if that's where it goes i mean
it's fine
i mean i'm not going to complain but
because that's i mean you're already
established there
yeah so it's like going to tv it's
almost like okay
now you got to herd them to this as
opposed to sounds like they're already
invested like youtube is almost a
is a tv channel yeah especially with the
amount of eyeballs you're getting is
more than
yeah a lot of tv shows yeah yeah but is
there something just to that
you you just love martin and you think
the desi bank show is like a martin so
you just want to see it on tv just for
you yeah
man it's like a dream like a you know
it's like a big thing
to like yeah me growing up watching
martin and being inspired by his shows
and you know
eddie murphy being my favorite actor you
know i'm saying
i want to be able to do some of the
things that they did as well but in my
way not saying i want to be like
them but in a dizzy way you know what
i'm saying so yeah
and this yeah man to get these numbers
you're getting a a thing you've
harped on a couple times is consistency
yeah that's the that's
going to more detail on that consistency
i'm someone like
putting out videos i mean you can't like
you know in the beginning stage you just
can't
put like one video out a week and just
think that's it
you know what i'm saying talking to him
you gotta put like in the beginning like
when it was 15 second videos like
literally
i probably posted like four videos a day
a day
a day okay you know until
i got to a point okay now i can slow
down now they seen me
a few times so now i can drop down to
two videos a day
and you know here come one minute video
so now it's like okay now i got one
minute videos
now i can do one video a day or
two to three videos a week you know i i
don't have to put too much pressure on
myself
drop it down to that much yeah four a
day to two a week you know what i'm
saying
oh okay you know once you done built
that
you know once you don't got to a point
where you can like okay cool
now you have the time to focus on other
you
focus on this but also focus on other
things as well
as far as like you know building on the
outside of your brand
you know what i'm saying doing things
are going to be able to take you to
another level
outside of social media those kind of
things like um